je sais même pas qui c'est clair
quand même révolutionner les pas de
conneries tu crois vraiment que je
regardais cette surface qui avait 7 ans
je vais regarder 7 sur 7 avec mes
parents à voir des gars qui parlent
politique qu'est-ce que je monte car le
cul alors regardez c'était un des plus
grands invités cette surface allez
à l'époque il avait vraiment que je
regardais ça non mais vous étiez trop
jeune mais non mais même tu crois
vraiment ma chérie je regardais ça
j'ai pas que ça à [__] non plus
c'est c'est de la fausse info et de la
fausse variété je n'aime pas j'aime pas
les sujets qu'ils mettent en avant
j'aime pas la façon dont il le traite
enfin franchement c'est très très loin
de moi à mon avis Hanouna je ne
correspond pas du tout non plus
alors je l'aime pas du tout
et deux et deux je vais vous dire la
vérité c'est qu'elle avait déjà parlé
mal de moi et je l'ai reconnu dans un
restaurant il y a de ça je suis plus un
an et je vous êtes qui vous nichons
moi je peux pas vous blairer non plus et
donc elle est partie du resto moi je dis
toujours la vérité quand je croise les
gens donc je te dis que je pouvais pas
labyer donc je pense elle savait que je
lui avais dit ça donc je pense qu'elle
savait que je l'aimais pas tout à
l'heure mais c'est vrai qu'on la connait
pas du tout la meuf elle permet de
parler de nous à chaque fois ça fait 40
ans qu'elle a pas fait de tennis sans
rigoler
c'est bon elle a fait une carrière de 50
ans
tous les soirs de donner des fausses
infos non non non
je te parle de qui elle représente
quelque chose quand même dans les années
90 c'est dans les années 80 mais
aujourd'hui quand tu as dit que nous on
donne des fausses infos alors pourquoi
c'est repris toute la journée ailleurs
si si elle a dit c'est pas ma came non
non non non
non plus ça va pas m'empêcher de dormir
ils sont vraiment les chéris voilà après
voilà j'ai jamais regardé de ma vie elle
était certainement très bonne elle était
bien mais il y avait trois chaînes
aujourd'hui maintenant il y a plein de
chaînes à droite de ce qu'on veut il y a
une liberté
non je suis pas je je je
que tu racontes et je suis pas des
choses c'est vous qui sucer les autres
toute la journée
c'est quoi la vraie variété hein je
trouve que c'est mal c'est vous qui
sucent
intellectuellement si nous on dit que
Anne Sinclair c'est rien voilà moi je
dis pas il y a pas d'excellence moi j'ai
dit que j'avais regardé vous avez le
droit mais on a le droit de dire nous
quand même
passeras les DVD si on reste encore
machin c'était regarder mais voilà il y
avait trois chaînes aujourd'hui il y a
plein de fausses variétés moi quand je
croise des gens dans la rue on a bien
rigolé hier avec l'émission on a bien
rigolé quand vous avez chanté on a bien
rigolé quand vous avez fait on a chanté
non non il y a encore ce matin on a bien
rigolé avec le chocolat ça nous a bien
fait marrer vous prenez du chocolat dans
la gueule alors c'est peut-être de la
fausse variété mais les gens aiment bien
non mais il y a plus de trois chaînes
c'est bon Raymond mais c'est pas parce
que je veux dire c'est pas parce qu'elle
nous accable que nous on doit l'accabler
de manière malhonnête intellectuellement
la raison bravo bravo tu es un génie tu
es mon champion bah écoutez voilà
je change de côté alors je suis désolé